[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash alright
what's up graduation stuff podcast we
got a lot of stuff coming at you today
who knows whatever episode it is but you
know was brought to you by we got it
alive by the apperance crystal Lea half
you go to the App Store wherever you get
apps and just type in crystal lead and
pull it up you see the podcast live
before you see everything else it also a
great overview of society hey guys watch
live shows coming up live shows coming
up we got a show in San Diego coming up
and you can get tickets we go to Chris
Leo Cobb and the cool thing about San
Diego is that that link was broken for
at least three weeks and we sold way
less tickets than we normally do and it
had to be up to me to find out what the
[ __ ] was going on and I called my agent
and then we got in touch with San Diego
and of course they said oh sorry the
website's been down for three weeks and
that's one of the reasons why San Diego
sucks
San Diego [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] blow blows
Folsom full of rows and full of rows and
[ __ ] and people who can't keep a
website together so go ahead get limited
tickets left we were gonna baby out of
show but now it just might be too too
lately lathe let's go to Chris Lea calm
is it [ __ ] annoying [ __ ] gasps we're
still gonna go to San Diego guess are we
gonna swear it ever to go to City who
ever again
yes are we gonna still go because they
give us but but buddy
yes um so yeah somebody on my app writes
this guy sounds different [ __ ] is wrong
with you dude um I think he's joking
but who knows cuz his name is cold you
never know if a guy named Cole is joking
or not uh I don't have your name be the
same name as what you get your stocking
when you're bad and Santa comes to town
so yeah so what's up dude
you can [ __ ] get tickets to San Diego
crystal calm the link is back working
and we got other things coming up at
going to [ __ ] I don't know where
we're going I don't know where we're
going I never know where we're going I
really don't ever know where we're going
I know always a date a week in advance
my babies but it's Chris its crystalline
this is congratulations podcast dude I
was in [ __ ] quirky and now I'm here
uh so yeah so I'm in LA now dude and
that's what's up
San Jose Las Vegas Santa Barbara
Riverside just City Fox was today to get
Beth Lee Pennsylvania
why is it called Bethlehem some [ __ ]
God every religious Rochester New York
Detroit let's get out of the shoulders
rumors about good they were she was a
special to Minneapolis Tampa Florida all
that [ __ ] but anyway dude yeah I'm back
in LA and I was in Albuquerque and I am
back in LA for about I was here for I'm
here for five or six days every time I
say six days I think a swingers when
they're like you got it you know when
the when they're talking about and
they're like you know what you know you
gotta wait you can't you can't call the
girl in the next day because then you
seem too eager you gotta wait two days
but then two days became kind of the
thing and then I could wait three days
it's not two days and then they're like
well so how long do you wait and they'd
have all say together they say six days
necessary dude when I when I used to
[ __ ] get chicks numbers when I used
to [ __ ] it I used to text them right
there looking at him in their [ __ ]
eyes do it you got to be gangster and
then dude and then you go like this and
you look at him and you say your move
anyway do it check these out bro we got
the no dent slides are these all sold
out anyway they might be sold out
but look at this [ __ ] dance no no
[ __ ] dense dude that's how we're
doing it here all summer so I'm putting
them back in the box dude you know I'm
happy to be home and it's amazing how
much happier I get when I'm home know
that I sold out okay cool hmm
and I'm chilling my babies so so here's
the deal
let's talk about some stuff I don't know
I love that you listen men III make
friends I make friends on set do it
that's what it is there's like 10 of us
on set doing this movie and I make
friends and that's it and that's that
dude you got to make friends where you
go right you got to make friends where
you go and I make friends where I go now
do I always make friends with the most
foreign person in the vicinity yes do I
do that my whole life yes why do I do
that I don't know do I like people who
seem different
yes was my mom always upset about it
when I was growing up in high school
because she can never be friends with
those people's moms because they only
spoke Russian
yes but did that stop me from being
friends with eidest Mountain Matt IDUs
mattis and Morgan doors Aki and another
guy named I think Robert I forget no it
didn't
so I [ __ ] you know I think I just as
a doctor now by the way so yeah so I
[ __ ] made friends with this really
famous guy in Germany whose name is
Matthias slow sand burger or some [ __ ]
never really asked him his last name I'm
not gonna do it though dude why do I
need to know somebody's last name if I
[ __ ] stare at him every day I'll just
call him Matthias dude he's the nicest
man I love this guy he looks 14 and he's
38 and he's in the movie and he said
literally the cutest thing to me that
I've ever heard in my entire life in the
[ __ ] world in my entire life I'm 39
never heard something cuter he said
Chris um I would love I might English I
I cannot wait what did he say perfectly
I want to say it I want to say it right
he said
my English is not that good so when you
tell jokes
I want to joke back with you um but
sometimes it takes a little bit of
thinking so I don't know how to say what
I want to say so hopefully in 2 1 or 2
years I will my English will be much
better and I will be able to joke with
you um I will be able to joke with you
then the most German [ __ ] ever and it
was cute and that was when I fell in
love with the dude hopefully in two
years I will be able to learn more
English and then joke with you he's the
nicest man he's my new best friend shows
shows schwag Hoffer that's what it is
there you go try Kaufer so yeah oh and
also he said we were out of place eating
food a bunch of us and he was like and
he was like he said he was looking at
the sandwich and he said uh what is what
is the touchy and I said ah dude he said
liturgy what is 'la touchy and I said do
you mean lettuce Stan Leela to Chi you
know dude I love the guy man he's my
friend there's nothing he can do about
it 'la to cheat dude loved it and he
said but it should be little Chi and I
was like you know what bro you're right
you're right so that's what it is it's
liturgy from now on dude I'd like a
[ __ ] turkey sandwich with some
mayonnaise onion and some cheese and
some litter Chi and some whole-grain
bread so anyway do it he's great
yeah but he's so famous in Germany and
it's crazy so it's like now we're
friends we got the most famous person in
Germany and the most famous person in
America chillin you know I mean him and
me so uh yeah I [ __ ] having a good
time though it's a million [ __ ]
degrees out there but it's all good
million [ __ ] degrees out there and my
schedule is this [ __ ] dude every day I I
work but also guess what I do that I've
never done before unless I've had a
[ __ ] 102 degree fever I fall asleep
before midnight never fall asleep before
midnight unless I have a hundred and
four degree fever or it's 104 degrees in
Albuquerque and I do that and I go to
bed now early and it's good for my body
and that's it and I wake up refreshed as
[ __ ] dude sometimes I'll wake up I'll
wash my hair and then let it air-dry on
the way to set put stuff in it and it's
on but yes so I get a good sleep dude
I get good sleep you know what I'm
[ __ ] is so actually annoying to me is
when people brag about how little sleep
they get hey dude I don't give a [ __ ]
also you're gonna die it gets to a
certain point where you don't just you
just can't catch up on your sleep and
then your body when it's like 60 is like
oh I guess I'll just die instead then
dude hey you won't let us sleep then
I'll just pass away for you we'll catch
up then and how about when people are
like I'll sleep when I'm dead now you'll
die when you're dead that's so dumb dude
you sleep now dude you need to sleep by
the way it is [ __ ] that we can't
sleep like that we have to sleep like at
least me [ __ ] 10 hours we should we
should get rid of that [ __ ] we should
figure out how to function without
sleeping and it's so annoying be like I
only need four hours dude that's all I
really need no you don't know you don't
know you know that's why you're an
[ __ ] a lot when people are like team
no sleep got a work keep on working I
don't sleep dude
leap hey man sleep you need to sleep
once I started sleeping really I never
got sick ever ever again sickness was
like K done I'll go we're good we're
good with your body
once I started [ __ ] sleeping well and
eating healthy like litter Chee and
stuff like that
sicknesses the antibodies were like we
don't have to work overtime what's in
anybody do I know so um yeah you got to
do it you got to [ __ ] sleep not team
no sleep team sleep I'm on team sleep so
yeah team sleep with stanley tucci oh
[ __ ] man I love it man people are always
trying to brag about [ __ ] how about when
people try to brag about [ __ ] that isn't
worth bragging about just like yeah bro
I only got [ __ ] three hours of sleep
every night this probably got like
[ __ ] twelve hours of sleep the whole
week meant just kind of [ __ ] burning
the candle at both ends
[ __ ] wincing down that a midnight oil
oh yeah dude sleep go to sleep man well
that doesn't impress me man that doesn't
impress me
chicks do it a lot too because they want
to like feel equal you know they'll be
like I don't sleep either just like a
guy you know chicks that like have
nothing to do but they [ __ ] act like
their days all busy that's hilarious to
me like I was just been been [ __ ]
going crazy oh yeah
what did you do yoga then boxing then
chilled a little bit had to catch up
with my [ __ ] team no sleep I barely
got any sleep last night really why Oh
cuz I had to get up and [ __ ] I'm
equal uh I had to get up and be all busy
all day being equal you know how hard is
being along yeah man I [ __ ] was
talking about Riley read the last
podcast that [ __ ] got some traction you
know it's funny do people I saw if
somebody posted a clip on YouTube by me
talking about and someone's like okay
you know member her name sure bro it's
so funny how huge like dude I don't I I
don't really I I I'm not trying like I
said this last time I'm not trying to
seem better than porn I [ __ ] hate
watch porn sometimes you know I don't I
don't watch it maybe watch porn once
honestly once I don't know every three
weeks and otherwise I used my head
because it's a I could do anything in
there you know but people are like like
dude hey how about this you're a virgin
you know I mean I'm not like dude and
and then in the middle of it I was like
oh yeah I remember the name I forget
[ __ ] Heath Ledger's name you know
like uh nobody's like oh dude yeah I
don't I don't I don't have anything to
prove to you [ __ ] man I don't
give a [ __ ] ok so there's so many people
in the comments of the YouTube thing
like okay you're always trying to
pretend like he doesn't know I don't
give a [ __ ] man I don't care if I'm
squirting squirting why you gotta lie I
made this whole podcast so I don't have
to lie and you're showing how much of a
[ __ ] dork you are by like
no I don't I don't know you know I don't
know she might be the only porn star
that I know I know some other ones and I
can't remember their names and that's
that all the ones I know Janine
Lindemulder she was the best man and
then my family kind of moved near her
and and I saw her a few times like just
with my eyes I was like that's her and
that's it when she was married to some
[ __ ] biker guy or some [ __ ] of course
yeah dude
but it's so funny when like guys when
like dorks are trying to get you with
like okay yeah we don't believe you you
know the name don't act like you know
it's like yo you're just showing how
much of a [ __ ] dorky you are like not
everybody is a big [ __ ] open the door
dork like you I got a fake argument at
my head in my head today - another one
with a Starbucks where I think I called
somebody some something oh god this is
gonna be a bad story because I don't
even remember the premise of it so it's
all good but I remember thinking uh I
remember thinking that I've called
someone a name and someone was like that
hurt my feelings and then in my head it
got all out of control on Twitter and
people were like crystal you called this
person that whatever say it's a dork or
whatever and that's not cool and I was
like I know and I in my head I was like
just be a dork who gives a [ __ ] it's
fine own that [ __ ] dude you know people
are so upset in my head
own it people in my head maybe in two
years I will be able to joke with you
it's cute it's cute so
do a team no sleep man team dead uh yeah
so I got to go back to Albuquerque um
[Music]
dude I was talking to my friend and he
said that his buddy
used to this is an insane thing to me
this is so insane so I in my whole life
I've never in my whole life had had sex
with a stranger unprotected ever in my
life ever I've always used a condom
first time having sex with somebody and
I like if you do that if you have sex
without a condom the first time you meet
somebody what's going on
do you understand hey hey if you have
sex with somebody who has a random [ __ ]
and you don't use a condom hey what's
going on you have to wrap it up dude you
just have to dude because of do you know
why and people are like herpes aids
you're not gonna get AIDS if you're just
plucking you know I mean unless you're
like deep down in like Colombia or some
[ __ ] and you're just like walking around
the forest and you see somebody in it
and then you [ __ ] them then maybe you
might get hit you know but like you're
not just if you're just chilling out in
Wisconsin or Wisconsin as t-pain would
say it and you just like meet somebody
and then pluck them you're not gonna get
AIDS you know but like and also the
other thing is too like I got checked
like for the first time in a long time
this was a bit ago I mean you know one
of the times I got checked and I didn't
have I didn't have anything and
had been like years since I got checked
and I didn't have anything and I was
like what run it again and I didn't have
anything and I was like wow condoms work
dude do you know why they work because I
use them and I'm clean but uh papaya I'm
loving it but uh papaya but uh papaya a
lot a lot of the I'm loving it real but
I yep bye yeah so um bodily I thought
I'd let I'm loving it so yeah I got no
[ __ ] things so so yeah so but but
people are like yeah you don't want to
get [ __ ] a disease dude [ __ ] that how
about I don't want a random toddler I
don't want a kid dude that's the worst
STD to get you know what the worst STD
is to get Charlie or Samantha [ __ ] that
I'd rather have an STD on my junk than
one walking around my nice house Oh
[ __ ] everywhere I don't have to
change an STDs diaper I'm not talking
about if you forgot gonna have kids and
you love him and you love a person you
want to have a family cool but dude you
just pluck him and and bust him oh man
you know it's just crazy
it's just crazy because and oh and so I
was talking my buddy and he said his
buddy does it dude this isn't so insane
man and he would just meet a girl and he
would have sex with her and then he
would he would if he [ __ ] up and if
you like to make sure that like if that
she would like not have the kid or not
want to be with him he would after he
had sex with her when he was leaving
he'd say hey can I borrow 20 dollars
oh that's actually genius but also hey
dude just don't bust in her can I borrow
$20 imagine thinking like Oh feels so
good I gotta do the $20 thing afterwards
dude you suck as a human that's amazing
but also probably works how about $20 I
gotta get a cab that's amazing to me
we got a new sign here but I don't know
how long I'm gonna leave it up but we
got it if you're looking at the video
podcast you can see this this really
sweet girl made this for me at where
where was I in Atlantic City she gave it
to me
nah it's string art it's like a bunch of
string together which they it looks nice
it says congratulations that it's got
the [ __ ] sign on fire it's very cool
man I really like it and I met her and
her mom and her and her mom were so
sweet and I liked them and they made
that for me and now it's on the podcast
because she said she's a big fan of the
podcast and so now her artwork is on the
wall I don't know if will keep it just
for this episode or maybe have it one or
two episodes up or whatever we like I
always think like we should change the
artwork but then I never [ __ ] change
our work and [ __ ] I put this up I gotta
no dents [ __ ] you know but yeah she was
a sweetheart in her mom is a sweetheart
two sweethearts make sweet hearts
sweethearts mothers become daughters
daughters become John Mayer song mothers
become daughters and daughters to come
mothers and their mothers grandmothers
and they die but then mother
mother yeah so I'll do some ads now you
know quip
the easiest way to ease back into a
routine started up before September
especially if you're headed back to
school simplify the morning and evenings
now with a simpler electric toothbrush
from clip time to sonic vibrations cover
the basics of every part of your mouth
and just take two minutes twice a day
the mirror mount puts brushing front and
center in your bathroom so you'll
remember to bookend the day using your
new brush it also looks cool on there
and the lightweight compact design means
you can bring it along with you on those
last summer weekend getaways so enjoy
sleeping in then ease back into the
swing of things with a smile
quick is great for equip is great for me
and it's great for keeping me in my
routine at home and on the road that's
why I love quip and that's why it's
perfect for getting back into a routine
clip starts at just $25 and if you go to
get clip comm / Congrats right now you
can get your first refill pack for free
that's your first refill pack free at GE
tqu yp.com / congrats román most guys
have tried different ways to last longer
but saying the Pledge of Allegiance in
your head or counting backwards from 10
doesn't always work that's funny I used
to have this joke with my buddy David
Meyer check where we're if you're like
trying to have sex and not you know
finished too early that he's hurt be
thinking you'd start thinking of
different things and we would be and we
would always be like like Calvin and
Hobbes Calvin and Hobbes Calvin and
Hobbes for Xero like to be having sex
thinking Calvin and Hobbes Calvin and
Hobbes we were 16 doing that dumb joke
anyway the folks at Rome in a men's
health company are changing the game
with Roman swipes the secret to
longer-lasting sex Roman swipes are a
clinically proven way to last longer in
bed
they're effective easy to use and
fast-acting but don't require a
prescription Roman can ship swipes to
you in discrete unmarked packaging and
each swipes packet is small enough to
hide in your wallet for whenever you
need it
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your partner so you can last longer
without worrying they're super easy to
use just take swipes out of the pocket
swipe it on let it dry and you're good
to go
that's it get $10 off your first order
of swipes and free 2-day shipping at get
Roman dot-com slash babies that's get
Roman dot-com slash babies for $10 off
and free 2-day shipping get Roman comm
slash babies so and then you can say can
I borrow $20 after sex up it if you
really don't want that girl to keep that
baby hey can I brought $250 do you mind
if I borrow 5 K now what you know what
really bummed me out I was thinking
about this today this past week like I
was thinking about high school I was
thinking about I was going all school
not just high school I think about my
elementary school asking about high
school all the things that I've done in
my life
and I was thinking about them fondly
like I was thinking about like mostly
like how it was fun and then I thought
about how I how did I feel though when
it was happening and a lot of the time I
felt not happy I felt like like in high
school it's a very awkward time you know
or you're growing up you're like I
wasn't I wasn't you know I didn't I even
feel comfortable you didn't feel
whatever it was you felt out of place
and and I thought well that's
interesting that now I look back on that
fondly and it makes me happy to think
about that time when in actuality it
wasn't necessarily it wasn't as though
the happiest of times right so I thought
about how retrospect kind of like candy
coats everything
and then I was thinking about all the
things in my life that I want to do and
I was getting excited for them you know
whatever it is having a family doing my
next next next Netflix special you know
[Music]
whatever it is lunch even tomorrow I get
to have a lunch tomorrow at that place I
like or I'm going to Las Vegas in three
weeks I can't wait to [ __ ] hang with
my buddies and try to [ __ ] up jump
the boogie you know and I was extinct
about all the things I was excited about
and then I was thinking about doing all
of those things I think about going to
Vegas with your friends think about
getting to do that think about if next
week you and your buddies got to go to
Las Vegas without your wife without your
girlfriends or if you don't have one it
doesn't matter maybe you're gonna go
plucking an up jump the boogie with your
friends okay you'd be so [ __ ] excited
wouldn't you you'd be so excited to just
go let off some steam
now what we know is if you're over 30 it
wouldn't be as good as you made it out
what you thought it was gonna be because
that's what happens you go [ __ ] yeah
let's do this
and you go and you get to the [ __ ]
Club in Vegas or whatever it is you like
oh that's okay we go to the strip club
and you're like oh I thought was maybe
is gonna gonna meet a chick and maybe I
was gonna start dating a stripper and it
didn't happen you let your fantasy go
run wild but that's what keeps you going
help my point is is it's never as good
as you think it's gonna be and
retrospect candy coats everything so
that means the worst time is now ha ha
ha that sucks dude if if looking back on
things that weren't necessarily good
make it better and if you're excited for
something that's not gonna be as
exciting as you think it is then the
worst time is now
and that's all you ever have now we're
[ __ ]
see ya all good we're [ __ ]
let's all living it together it sucks
the most
now it sucks the most now I kissed I
can't stop it I can't I can't stop it
I'm best yes I always want the [ __ ]
thing to be a kill switch and it's not
yes I always want to [ __ ] start
something when I hit the key and then
have it be a kill switch [ __ ] yes and it
never is it just starts the phone over
the [ __ ] so over again yes be much
funnier to cut it out yeah so that's it
that was the profound thought I had
today at least you get to look forward
to things that won't be that good you
know what I'm talking about but
sometimes this [ __ ] surprise you right
when the [ __ ] pops off when you really
do up jump the boogie right but it's
never when you expect it though remember
those times you were just driving around
in the valley with your old roommate and
[ __ ]
and you were like yeah whatever then
something happened uh like a you know
like some cool [ __ ] happen and you were
just like whoa [ __ ] yeah dude I didn't
know that was gonna be awesome
and then it happened then it's all good
actually that guy I remember my old
roommate
my old roommate and his buddy who I'm
still friends with uh now you know now
his buddy is one of my [ __ ] really
really good friends you know how that
always happens you're like you think you
have a friend and then you meet their
friend and then you guys get closer and
you're like that's the real friend
anyway so I met that guy and we still
keep in touch yeah I still keep in touch
the other guy too but I used to do this
thing with like waiters and [ __ ] or
anytime someone will give you something
like if you were like at a [ __ ] mail
place and they were to that you were to
mail something and they give you a
receipt or whatever I used to I used to
do this thing for me this is how [ __ ]
dorky I am
instead of saying thanks man I'd say I'd
say I'd say I'd say x-men but I would do
it and they would never know they would
never you know they'd never catch on
because either there's two things that
were gonna happen they're either not
gonna hear it cuz they're so ready to
hear thanks man
so say x-men and they think oh or so
they either think they either just hear
thanks man
or they hear me say x-men and they think
well he obviously didn't say x-men I
misheard it so I'll just let it go so we
were at this restaurant house of pies in
on in [ __ ] Hollywood you know and I
was telling my buddies about this how I
say x-men sometimes and it's funny for
me and he was like really and I said
yeah I say guys come by and it would
drop the food off our x-men and they say
no problem cuz I'm [ __ ] obviously not
in their head saying x-men but so my
buddy Mitchell is like oh alright I'm
gonna try it I was like alright cool and
I was like but listen you can't say
[ __ ] x-men like it's thanks man like
you can't be like thanks man like that's
a [ __ ] you got to [ __ ] say x-men
you don't have to be like x-men but you
got to be like nice man yeah be like
x-men so the waiter drops the food off
and my buddy says x-men and the waiter
says did you say x-men
[Laughter]
bro I don't know if there's ever been
anything funnier that's happened like
I've been doing it for years nobody's
ever and the waiter says did you say
x-men for [ __ ] sake man and he was
like oh no I don't know just saying
x-men to nobody yet you'd be like this
what what as far as the [ __ ] Luther
it's also even better cuz like the x-men
movies weren't even like popping yet
like it was just like a thing that dorks
wouldn't know about it wasn't like
Marvel was so big this is [ __ ] x-men
for no reason when he gets a [ __ ]
waffle mm-hmm ah [ __ ] dude I love [ __ ]
like that man
I love [ __ ] like that oh [ __ ] I was had
my hands like in my [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
knees together rolling around on that
[ __ ] pleather booth okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] man farmers dog dog food
companies love using fancy recipe names
and colorful pictures of real meat and
veggies on their bag but it seems no
matter the brand or the price or the
ingredients on the label all you find
inside are on it and if I dry it out
brown nuggets why do we accept this as
food let alone as healthy food for
living beings as awesome as dogs alright
what kind of beef or carrots can sit on
a shelf for months or even years we eat
highly processed preservative heavy food
for every meal of our lives and remain
healthy so why should dogs are the
healthiest food for your dog is real
fresh unprocessed food introducing the
farmers dog the company that helps dogs
live longer you love your dog right you
want to live long so you got to get this
farmers dog I use it my dogs love it
they gobble it up the recipes are made
fresh and delivered directly to your
door I got to just compete a short
questionnaire and a personalized that
develop developed meal plan is created
for your doctor
start feeding your dog better today get
50% off your two-week trial of fresh
healthy food at the farmer's dog calm
slash Congrats plus you get free
shipping just go to the farmer the
farmers dog calm / congrats to get 50%
that's 50% off your two week trial
that's the farmers dog calm / Congrats
manscaped support for congratulations
comes from manscaped who's number one in
men's below-the-belt grooming manscaped
offers precision engineered tools for
your family jewels are you I use I use
it they sent me the stuff and I used it
to keep clean I never used to love doing
it keeping it clean Minh liked to look
but you can do it with this very easily
and it doesn't Nick it you know they got
like a different guards and it's just I
did it and then I just stared at myself
in the mirror for a while just hanging
out and I looked rad I really looked rad
so if you want to look rad get this the
manscaped has redesigned the electric
trimmer their lawn mower 2.0 has
proprietary skin safe technology can't
go wrong with that
so this trimmer won't Nick or snag your
nuts manscaping also has the crop
preserver and anti chafing baldie are in
a moisturizer you get you'll you always
put children on your armpit so why not
putting children on your I mean they're
why wouldn't you do that your balls will
thank you get 20% off free shipping and
a free travel bag with the code congrats
at manscaped comm that's 20% off with
free shipping and a free travel bag at
manscaped calm and use code congrats
congratulations brought to you by this
what they want me to do congratulations
but you buy cash
I'm gonna hyperventilate dude I feel
light-headed
he says biggest possible breath in cash
I mean that'll be 40 minutes download
cash app today for the App Store or
Google Play Store I wonder how long
you'd do it
I mean I that's 1/4 of how long I can do
it so and they want me to 1 2 3 4 or 5
that'll be [ __ ] 14 minutes
yeah get cash up though I use it to pay
all my friends um
yeah so that's what's up do unit that's
what's up
did you uh dude x-men try that with your
friends try that with your friends dude
did you uh have you guys seen the
fortnight competition the guy won three
million dollars that's cool I don't even
think about that
when somebody tells me something like
that it goes out of my brain and then I
got do whatever I do but I wrote it down
cuz I was like maybe I should talk about
it but I don't know man video games
right video games are surprisingly fun
to watch though I don't know why I used
to have a my buddy my friend used to say
nothing's more boring than watching
someone play video games and I totally
disagree with him some guy one fortnight
the competition and made three million
dollars and he's like 20 he's like 2016
he's sixteen years old and there was a
guy that was 24 that was repping for the
old hears like I'm repping for the old
guys and he's 24 bro fortnight World Cup
was a kid's paradise it says here this
kid won three million dollars Wow 49
player Kyle booga got Gaia gears Dorf
won the World Cup solo finals two World
Cup the 19 your sorry the 16 year old
North America East Player finished with
59 points and takes home a prize of 3
million
cool the second place finisher 11.8
million dollars damn these guys is names
you know Booga psalm epic whale creo
damn dude
even the tenth place winner one two
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
whatever fat you know nate is the worst
one with a lie in it you [ __ ] what do
you are a per in the 90s Nate one
[ __ ] half a million DJ Quik one three
and then [ __ ] Redman and Keith Murray
remember Keith Murray
dude that guy I love Keith Murray
because everyone else was like making
names and he was like I'm just gonna be
my name DJ quick to you i k and all that
[ __ ] and did you in Keith Murray was
like all good I'll just be the guy I am
loved loved Keith Murray love all love
olih rap is the only you don't I think
hurts rap rap is the only genre of music
where there's a old-school why do you
label it that you know I mean if you
didn't label it that then the guys who
were old-school would still be the could
still be relevant but the second you say
they're old-school it makes them not
relevant anymore like I'm sorry but Eric
sermon [ __ ] rips a lot of you young
guys don't know what the [ __ ] that is
like if you play for at night you
probably don't know who Eric sermon is
but he ribs like I guess jay-z would be
old-school but he's still kind of he
still makes music that [ __ ] kind of
rips I guess jump out like yeah who the
[ __ ] you wit
jumped out like yeah who the [ __ ] you
wit you know so I don't know if ya video
game I guess they're gonna start
building stadiums for video games which
is which is wild you know think about
like the actual people in the stadium
watching the fortnight World Cup
I would I would argue there's never been
a more a bigger group of unathletic
people in a stadium than in that moment
these guys just like well you know I
think fat honestly you know I mean he's
number 10 but you know he could move up
a few seeds fat just looking good Nate
is looking good you know honestly I I
get Booga could take it away but you
know it's like 1.8 million for second
place that's not too shabby like you
know that's a thing like oh you know if
I played video games and someone was
like all [ __ ] you're a dork I'd be like
you goddamn right I am you are goddamn
right I am named Colin is the [ __ ]
somebody wrote me on Instagram about my
tattoo and he was like your tattoo sucks
this and that I don't you know I'm
exactly what he said he said you don't
get it on your hand the first tattoo
trying too hard and I was like oh yeah
it was like that's why I guess you're
trying to keep sixteen-year-old girls
liking you or something and I was like
why are you so concerned you know I had
to do a [ __ ] clap I had the fungus
sent him to Denny's it's all good but he
[ __ ] ordered you know he sat down at
Denny's so at the Grand Slam him and I
said why are you so concerned with 16
year old girls you [ __ ] pedophile I
said also you're fat cuz I looked at his
profile and he was [ __ ] hefty and he
said oh you're just gonna name call bro
you don't get to do that
and you walked in this Denny's this is
what we serve you don't you don't know I
can't help but you wanted to [ __ ] I
can't help it that you can't go back in
time and erase the beginnings of that
but you can't dude are you do you have a
phone booth that goes back in time that
sprays purple and green mist if you do
then go ahead and try to delete that but
you can't because those don't exist yet
so why is your nose face in my nose
well what am I ever talking about you
know how sometimes people are like you
know how people are like there was
there's something that there's something
it's called something where you feel
like you're a fraud in your career
yes imposter syndrome I just found out
what impostor syndrome is and and I was
talking about it and then and then I
looked it up and it's it's whenever it's
when you feel you're bringing up it's
when you feel like you're you're you're
an imposter even though you're really
doing what you're doing
impostor syndrome is also known as is a
psychological pattern in which
individual doubts or accomplishment has
a persistent internalized fear of being
exposed as a fraud and I was despite
external evidence of their competence
the those experiencing this phenomenon
remain convinced that they're frauds
your husband and it was like so like
almost everybody has it and I was like I
never felt that way and I thought oh am
i sociopath like dude
if someone were to be like like what I
don't get it I'm gonna put it back yeah
I don't know some of it seems like
normal [ __ ] like fear of failure I guess
being a comedian is [ __ ] different
though you subject yourself to so much
[ __ ] hate and like possible like
scrutiny because you're just standing in
front of you know like the other night I
had to follow Leslie Jones who literally
I mean nobody kills harder than her you
know she's in ghostbusters and [ __ ] and
she's on SNL and I was like [ __ ] I gotta
follow Leslie tonight and I looked and I
walked in and she she was doing like 35
she runs the light all the time and I
was like okay the more someone does time
the harder it is you know if you do 15
minutes is fine but she did 35 minutes
and I was like did this is so annoying
how long she's doing and and I was like
oh I've been starting to go up you know
and I was like [ __ ] I'm just gonna
eat [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] who cares
cuz I've eaten [ __ ] before and I peeked
my head in what she was onstage and she
was screaming in the face of someone in
the front row and she was saying and
everyone was they weren't even laughing
they were howling it was like a sermon
and I was I gonna eat [ __ ] when I go up
there and she got offstage and I went
upstage and I killed I didn't eat [ __ ]
but like you know I don't know where I
was going I wasn't trying to brag for
sure my point was something else I guess
being a comedian yeah you just don't
give a [ __ ] you have to not give a [ __ ]
because if I were to go up on stage
after her and you could sense that I
give a [ __ ] then you wouldn't laugh
because I always say that like when a
comedian bombs a comedian doesn't truly
bomb this is what I have always said
since I've done stand-up a comedian
doesn't truly bomb unless the
unless the comedian cares that he's
bombing if a comedian doesn't care that
he's bombing it he's not bombing because
the audience can smell that and they're
like I [ __ ] he knows it's funny but
he's just having a rough night who cares
but the second the comedian does a
[ __ ] nervous laugh or a swallow or
like I don't know I guess I thought that
was funny then you're bombing dude
you're out in the middle of the ocean
you know but if you don't care it
doesn't matter then no anyway get your
[ __ ] no dent slides these are the
[ __ ] dude they really are or if you have
dents you can just get one and hop
around on the left foot if you want to
do some questions or you want to do some
what do you call it also do we have miss
connections or now we should do next
time we're now looking we do Albuquerque
miss connections I've ever done that we
have all we did okay cool I don't
remember anything that's great cool cool
cool I'm gonna have a dementia when I
get a little oh that's cool
I should do more Sudokus oh cool that's
what they say helps it my [ __ ] you
know Frank at washed Frank
okay possible change it although maybe
there's meaning behind it accurately a
hit Chris why are your forearms so
smooth yeah you know what sometimes
people ask me if I shaved my forearms
I've never shaved my forms in my life
I've never had electrolysis
I just [ __ ] I just look [ __ ] good
dude my forearms are just smoothie [ __ ]
man I have hair little hairs on there
you know it's on there you know I guess
I guess I'm lucky cuz you can see the
striations down my [ __ ] muscles
you'd be like oh that guy obviously uses
kettlebells like what the [ __ ] because
you know I don't know but they're
goddamn smooth man I'm living it up
while I still can man cuz maybe when I'm
60 I'll start getting hairy or some [ __ ]
yeah I don't know
I have smooth skin I have real smooth
skin for real like when when when people
touch my back they're like what's going
on dude besides the fact that they're
like oh this is obviously where they
shot Lord of the Rings because it's so
mountainous they go oh but why is it so
why is it so smooth and I go that's when
I look at him and I say Anointed One and
they go yeah maybe but yeah you know so
yeah I'm smooth as [ __ ] my hands bro if
you were to hold my hand like we were at
a park
you'd go huh is that butter alright next
question
I'm just smooth as [ __ ] bro washed Frank
hey actress alia how would you fight
someone if they had called you that oh
wait oh imagine this is a me imagine
living in the 70s and having to fight
another man because he called you a jive
Turkey jive Turkey
Hey a curse Thalia how would you fight
someone if they had to call you that we
know how you like coming up with the
fake fight scenarios oh yeah I do do
that huh I probably is carrying around a
[ __ ] whip or a gun or a [ __ ] or
error or poison and try to shove it in
their mouth I don't know I don't care
you know who cares if someone calls me a
name it doesn't matter to me you know
what I mean that's the whole thing
without going back to on the you own it
know how [ __ ] is it to try and catch a
fly with your hand it's actually
literate I mean sometimes it's you know
how we say in this park is it's all the
sir comes full circle that could
literally be the least [ __ ] thing you
could do if you do it like if you're
just chilling in Ascot and a fly goes
BAM and you catch it
that's not [ __ ] but if you're like
[ __ ] about it it could be [ __ ] yeah
that's not really that [ __ ] like
getting into a car what was the guy who
said getting out of the car backwards or
something that was so big
getting up what was it yeah getting out
of the backseat of a two-seater
oh yeah that's so [ __ ] like there's no
way to do that cool even if you have
sunglasses on that's funny is there
another one or no whatever at least my
back hurts and stop giving me advice
about about it you know when I say stuff
like on my back hurts on the podcast I I
get like [ __ ] 9 DM is a day where
it's like you owe if you're really we're
gonna want you just ya know you know are
you a fan of mine then you know I'm not
gonna listen to you let my back hurt so
I could just chill you know it is I'm
looking at I'm looking at [ __ ] my
email right now because I'm being
respectful on you [ __ ] and
guess what I got an offer to do a casino
here wow that's pretty good
what it's bad to do something uncouth
[Music]
where is it near San Francisco when is
it oh oh it's an April okay cool yeah
that's way too far
sure why not look how I do it to my
agent sure why not in all caps and I'm
gonna write I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
there were that's what I did sent it to
my agents look to prove it that's how we
do it dude you gotta give a [ __ ] less in
your life oh they just responded they
don't want me yeah dude
[ __ ] yeah man life's good baby life's as
good as you make it so make it good I'm
gonna be the mayor
I like Buddha jej is that as how you say
it that guy just seems really like you
know I
I'm not political it's just like how
about the lady that's like a hippie
she's just like they're like how do you
think we could beat Donald Trump and
she's like love and cookies who's that
lady you even know I'm talking about the
one with the beaker on the side of her
mouth I called it a beaker man did I
talk about this in the podcast I will
call beauty marks beakers when I was a
kid my mama I did it like it was a word
that existed Madonna
it was probably how era Cindy Crawford
I'd be like she'd be like she's
beautiful yeah but I don't like her
beaker and my mom's like what I'll [ __ ]
are you talking about what's a beaker
and I was like the thing on its side of
her mouth and she's like that's a beauty
mark and I just called it a beaker and I
think that that's what it I thought
that's what it should have been called
and I just said it like that's what it
should have been called and so I call
them beakers that's what it should be
called yeah what's her name Marianne
Williamson I always like the candidates
that are like a runnin that are just
like obviously not gonna [ __ ] make it
like just give up I guess it's like like
remember when that guy used to have run
for the green the independent what was
his name
no yeah him but yeah Nader dude that guy
would [ __ ] everything up like just dude
stop bro like nah but it's good for the
party
also what an annoying last name Nader
Nader sounds like some [ __ ] [ __ ] that
would be around in the 90s like that I
don't know what I'm saying it doesn't
matter who cares but he [ __ ] it up
Pete Budaj edge he he's just like
succinct and cool and like no [ __ ]
I would here's one of the reasons why I
want him to be the nominee
because I think him arguing with Trump
would be the funniest I think he would
have so many [ __ ] slams and obviously
Trump has so many slams just because he
literally call somebody like Doody head
but like he would just I think that's
the guy to scare that would scare Trump
out of all the guys because it's just
he's so young he's gay you know Trump
would probably be like I want to say I
mean even though he does doesn't give a
[ __ ] what he says he would be he would
be like I can't make fun of gay you know
like they're just he just feels like a
landmine for Trump footage so I want him
to be the guy now so far I don't know if
he'd win it'd be cool to have a gay
president it would be [ __ ] awesome to
have a gay president I I don't I don't
know if America would be ready to vote
for one like I don't know there's so
many [ __ ] prejudiced people out there
but I didn't think Obama was gonna get
it and he did not surprise me and that
was really cool but yeah dude if we had
a gay president that would be the [ __ ]
just principle of it you know oh wow
Trump calls Pete Buddha jej Alfred E
Newman that's kind of funny actually
that's the thing about Trump man
I mean he's funny you know he is funny
like you can hate him all you want but
he's funny and that's that's almost like
sucks because it's like that's people
like him because of that um anyway yes
that's good we can finish up download
download the cash up for free on the App
Store or Google Play market and you can
download the Chris D'Elia app and you
see the podcast before anyone else
support the show by buying merch at
store Chris Lea dot-com or you could
just go to Chris Lee calm and follow the
links there you get these slides over
there the no dents and them futures too
bright shirt which is a Elissa [ __ ]
go to Miami and where that subscribe to
the YouTube channel and and tweet me and
stuff and maybe I'll answer your
question if if I want to I only do what
I want though so it's all good like in
this week everyone should just do more
what they want you know even if it's
gonna upset somebody just do more what
you want man that's what my thing is do
it it's better that way man when
somebody [ __ ] does something that
they want in front of me I get so happy
[ __ ] [ __ ] these things man when you know
what I'm like you're in a relationship
and chicks are like yeah I want you to
go to the thing and you're like I don't
want to dude and they're like ah I would
want to go to your thing and you're like
yeah my shit's fun that's so annoying
that don't go don't come then I don't
want anybody to come if they don't want
to [ __ ] come
uh don't cry like don't call my show
like you know how some comedians are
like yeah come to my show maybe you know
when you're coming up you're like yeah
you [ __ ] handing out for it don't come
if you don't want come anyway I got a
meeting with Stan Lila Tucci so I have
to go I'll talk to you guys later you
guys are the man you guys are the woman
you guys are the [ __ ]
bye bye
[Music]